hey guys i am just mcdonald it is the
25th of march you're watching gamespot
news and thanks for tuning in first up
if you have money to burn how that you
don't literally burn it and instead by
this $3,000 graphics card nvidia have
announced the super-powered geforce gtx
titan z which promises to deliver
supercomputer inspired performance and
you're bloody well hope so for 3 grand
the nifty card is built around to Kepler
GPUs and 12 gigabytes of dedicated frame
buffer memory it features two gk110
chips and is powered by 5720 processing
cores due to the fact that the cards
GPUs are tuned to run at the same clock
speed and feature what they're calling
dynamic power balancing there's no issue
of a performance bottleneck over to the
software side today oddworld crater has
said that battlefield 4 shipped with
dirt all over it and continue to use a
lot of other colorful language so we
better use our safeword panda instead
Lorne Lanning spoke in reference to the
bug heavy shooter saying panda that
business I don't want to play with that
business I'd rather not make games and
go pandering being a slave for public
companies who care more about their
shareholders than they do about their
customers he went on to say that the
devs new battlefield wasn't ready to be
shipped but business decisions resulted
in it being pushed out early do you guys
agree with learning or do you think the
comments are unwarranted it needs of
where you can get cool stuff cheap that
450 Allah Titan full and Xbox one bundle
is popping up everywhere it's no longer
just the party retailers like amazon
best buy and walmart who are offering up
the fifty dollar discount but also
microsoft itself and target the run is
supposedly limited so if you're keen to
pick this one up yourself i'd get a move
on laughs up a room at second GPU to be
residing within the xbox one has been
confirmed to be just that II bruma
Director of Product Planning Albert
Penello has said there's no second GPU
nor is there a stacked GPU he identified
that it was perhaps the DirectX 12
announcement which got the rumor mill
rolling as for how DirectX 12 is going
to impact upon the Xbox one AD van
misty performance over time I'm being
promised but there aren't any specifics
to speak of be sure to let me know what
stories you cared about today either in
the comments section down below or you
can do so on my Twitter that is all I
got for you today but be sure to join
the same time and place tomorrow for
more good stuff